[Music]
we have lost sight today of the
possibility of linking masculinity to
goodness and this is above all what i
want to defend how to get there
we could as grayson perry suggest begin
by questioning outdated versions of
masculinity
we could say as he does that masculinity
needs to change because most versions of
it are a blight on society in his words
or we could shift a little and say that
perhaps we need to resurrect what was
good about older kinds of masculinity in
the name of a different image of the
present and the future
many men are already good which is to
say they look after themselves and
others care for their families sacrifice
their time and energy to making the
world a better place for all
it is unfair and untrue therefore i
think to down men and masculinity as
such
the general social attitude today is
however to be worried that masculinity
is damaging to both boys and men and
girls and women
the american psychological association
guidelines for psychological practice
with boys and men from 2018 states that
in western culture the dominant ideal of
masculinity has moved from an
upper-class aristocratic image to a more
rugged and self-sufficient ideal
the apa stresses that these ideals are
in any case damaging stereotypes and
might quote potentially alienate sexual
and gender minority men from a complete
male identity as well as quote ostracize
some gay bisexual trans transgender and
gender non-conforming individuals
while noting that quote although
privilege has not applied to all boys
and men in equal measure in the
aggregate males experience a greater
degree of social and economic power than
girls and women in a patriarchal society
the authors go on to add that quote male
privilege often comes with a cost in the
form of adherence to sexist ideologies
designed to maintain male power that
also restrict men's ability to function
adaptively
following the historic economic and
social masculinization of women i.e
women's entry into many of the worlds
that used to belong solely to men we now
sometimes also witness the feminising of
men in the form of an imposed guilt upon
boys and men merely for behaving in
masculine that is to say today in
negative ways being boisterous loud
domineering and so on
certain kinds of behavior come to be
rewarded over others we can see this all
the way to the job market where many
economies have themselves become
feminized that is to say less physical
more dependent on traditionally feminine
skills such as communication and
sociability
western economies largely do not require
large amounts of physical labour
this has an impact on the values of our
culture at large
if it is positive that men are less
manly than they were in the past
then this is part of our cultural
evolution
but far better to note what has been
lost i think than to pretend that this
is the only way that things must
henceforth be
in the west compared to the past and to
many other societies we see a
generalized abdication of male
instruction and a lack of initiation
rituals in the passage from boyhood to
manhood
if masculinity is in trouble today it is
because our understanding of humanity as
a whole is in trouble
what would instead a masculinity
directly related to an idea of the good
look like today
it can only begin by resurrecting the
necessity of virtue as such which is to
say to recognize the capacity of men to
be good in the first place
in order for the question of the good to
even be asked we have to return to older
ideas of virtue boys and men must be
allowed to be good to become better and
celebrated for doing so
so there is it seems to me this very
deep and ancient question at the heart
of what it means to be a man or woman
namely what it means to be a good man
and a good woman this is by no means an
easy question when today there either
seems to be no answer or too many
answers to it the question of sex is a
question of morality though this is
something we tend to scoff at these days
as if there's any one way to be a good
man how could we know uh [ __ ] off no one
tells me how to live
it sounds religious or conservative to
link one's moral being to one's sex it
is to be anti-modern regressive
restrictive oppressive don't we live in
an age in which we can choose how to
live as individuals decoupled from our
sex are we not sublimely historically
free
if we talk today about being a good man
we no doubt hear the shudder inducing
echo of an earlier narrow understanding
of masculinity
we think of the punishment of men who
failed to live up to an ideal
but the emphasis here should be on
trying to live as honestly and
realistically as possible not about
living up to some impossible standard or
imagining that there is one ideal way of
being a man
for example by learning how and when to
use one's judgment and strength both
physical and mental one also learns how
not to misuse these things
people are good men or women because
they do good things or try to not
because an individual says of themselves
that they are good or because they have
the right line on an issue
the question of what these good things
are is complicated and must be
discovered through trial and error
but we can begin from the assumption
that we are all unlikely to find out
what goodness is from a culture based in
the first place on the manipulation of
desires for negative ends that is to say
an amoral consumerism that panders to
our basis desires
in order then to discover what it means
to be a good man or woman we must
question how the world today is sold to
us and need to be prepared to look at
ourselves in the mirror without the
protection of cynicism or the
distraction of endless cover stories
about how progressive modern life is
supposed to be
in our age the kind of freedom often
offered by a hedonistic capitalism has
tried to turn us all into something less
than human
rather we are commodities of a kind
person-sized objects that sell
themselves while simultaneously
accumulating things
our rewards such as they are tend to
draw us deeper into the world of things
and often towards oblivion and
distraction
in the realm of thought social media has
revealed that the punishments for
disagreeing with others can be severe
it may be that we all need to get
offline sooner rather than later the
better to remember who we are and who
our real friends are
we are often compelled to forget that
free and simple pleasures conversation
walking outside being in nature
are also available to us
beyond endless consumption the nervous
avoidance of serious questions or a lack
of confidence in how we handle ourselves
life can be
often very beautiful
what it means to be a man and what it
means to be a woman are precisely
questions that are posed implicitly or
otherwise in these sacred times and
these elevating places
only a cynical mindset seeks to diminish
experiences that are open to everybody
you